[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to the full review of the google
pixel 3 xl and also welcome to the first
wider widescreen video i've done so let
me know what you guys think of that so
this is the phone i've been using for
the past week and change and obviously
it's been leaked into oblivion so i kind
of knew what i was getting myself into
but there's still so much smart stuff to
talk about this is maybe the smartest
smartphone i've ever used with some
caveats so this video is going to be
mainly centered around pixel 3 xl but
everything i will say also applies to
the pixel 3 unless i say otherwise here
we go
so on the outside i really like the new
hardware of this phone it's pretty much
better in every way than the pixel 2
from the way it feels to the way it's
built the highlights of the pixel 2 are
still here so the stereo front-facing
speaker pair still here the squeeze for
assistant the two-tone back look but now
there are new materials and just a new
quality to it we all know the back is
now all glass but this two-tone look
comes from frosting the glass of the
lower part and it's impressive that it
actually gives you this soft touch feel
but as you can see
it's not perfect it can be very easily
scratched you might remember i did an
unboxing of this phone on instagram live
and within seconds of taking it out the
box without even ever putting it in my
pocket once there were these little
little tiny scratches in the back on the
soft touch part so it turns out those
tiny little scratches the micro
scratches they can buff out pretty
easily with your shirt or a microfiber
or something
they're definitely still there but
they're just really hard to see but this
major gash here this came while actually
shooting this video during the intro
shot to hold it still it was like
sandwiched between two batteries so like
not a normal place to be but then we
took it out and it had this
pretty much uh unfixable gash i really
don't think most phones would scratch
this bad from that amount of contact so
obviously that's the downside of the
soft touch glass
now if you want to protect it you
already know i'm more of a skins person
than a case person and the dbrand skin
can match the matte black if you want or
make the phone whatever color you want
it's a no-brainer and of course wireless
charging still works through a case or a
skin so there's a link below anyway with
this new build you get ip68 water
resistance that the pixel 2 didn't have
and like i said wireless charging is
welcome and this is the part where i
give a shout out actually to my favorite
wireless charger now the new pixel stand
it's 80 bucks and it's it's everything i
want a wireless charger to be it's great
anyway the buttons of the phone are
clicky and tactile and good the
fingerprint reader is exactly where it
should be if it's not going to be behind
the glass yet and they've even got
little touches like painting the inside
of the usb-c port black there's still no
headphone jack but it comes with usb-c
headphones in the box which is a lot
better than the opposite that apple's
doing of taking the dongle out the box
so it's mostly good news in the hardware
stuff on the outside of the three new
colors total i like matte black
everything
but if you're debating between the three
i think the white will actually show the
least scratches for what that's worth so
then around the front that's obviously
where things start to get interesting uh
pixel 3 and pixel 3 xl have great
screens objectively their panels are
made by samsung this year and we all
know how good samsung is at screens it's
a 5.5 inch flexible oled on the 3 and a
6.3 inch on the 3xl and both phones also
now have two front-facing cameras and a
pair of big front-facing stereo speakers
and the speakers are pretty good but
with a catch so i've compared them to
iphone 10s max and the razer phone some
of the loudest speakers in any phone and
these are every bit as loud if not
louder and they sound fuller and they
definitely have more bass but it just
distorts a little bit at the highest
volume and then they also vibrate the
whole bottom of the phone at loud
volumes it's not a problem at all i just
noticed like i would feel it more than
normal if i had loud music going in my
hand so then uh
the notch
at the top it's just you can't not talk
about this screen without talking about
the notch it's like a metaphor for the
whole phone you can't talk about this
phone without talking about that notch
so the fact is it doesn't really look
like any other notch on any other phone
it has this face it's really tall
but the weird thing is it's not actually
really that much bigger than a lot of
other notches here's what i mean this is
the iphone 10s and the notch is just
about the same volume as other notches
but it's narrower and taller instead of
slimmer and wider but this choice
assuming it was a choice shifts the
whole ui more down into the screen and
you lose more of the top ears as they
call it
that's just losing screen real estate
this my friends is what we call in the
business a poor use of space do they
absolutely have to go with this tall of
a notch i don't know google didn't
really tell us they didn't really
emphasize anything about it in the
keynote obviously like were they so set
on having two front-facing cameras and a
big speaker that they had to go with
this tall notch or were they so set on
this tall notch that they figured they
might as well throw in two cameras and a
front-facing speaker
i don't know but it is what it is the
truth is a week into using this phone i
don't pay attention to the notch anymore
like every other phone i've used with a
notch but i still want it to go away i
still want it to be smaller i'm
basically hoping notches and smartphones
are a temporary hurdle and we're kind of
over it by 2020 or 2022. maybe that's
just me being optimistic but until then
if you absolutely cannot deal with a
notch you can either get the smaller
pixel 3 and deal with a smaller phone
with a smaller battery or you can hide
the notch by ticking the developer
setting that permanently blocks out the
top notch section your call so i could
talk for a while about performance and
smoothness of android on this phone but
the bottom line is
it's good that's the short of it google
knows how to tune their own android
phone it's well optimized and this is
going to be one of the only phones with
android p for a while now on the four
gigs of ram i'll get to that in a second
but just the overall smoothness and
performance of pixel 3 has been great
i'd say my biggest complaint with the
software is probably just the gestures
honestly i've done an entire separate
video on all the new stuff with android
p including these gestures which were
optional at the time but now this is the
only navigation option and you're forced
to get used to it which i am but i still
don't prefer it so that's just me but
then past that pixel has all kinds of
little software tricks and smart
features possibly making this the
smartest smartphone i've ever used
google lens identifying things in front
of the camera all the time that's smart
the now playing feature i love this so
it'll tell you what song is playing in
the background of whatever room or car
you're in without you having to ask and
it keeps a rolling history of it that's
smart
and of course just google assistant in
general absolutely useful and call
screen call screen is super good i think
we've all noticed at some point there
seems to be more spam calls happening at
least to me i've noticed it so when
you're receiving an incoming call on
pixel 3 with call screen you can either
accept reject
or screen the call with google assistant
and when you do
google assistant picks up the phone call
hi the person you're calling is using a
screening service from google and will
get a copy of this conversation
go ahead and say why you're calling
yeah i'm the i'm the ups guy and i'm
downstairs
do you need to get a hold of them
urgently
yes if you don't answer then i have to
bring this 2020 mac pro back to the
factory
thanks connecting you now so basically
the live transcription it's great it
lets me know immediately if it's just a
spammer robot calling and then i can
hang up or mark it as spam or if it's a
real person but i actually found most
real people when they hear that google
assistant voice they either immediately
hang up or
they think it's a voicemail they leave a
voicemail and then they hang up so if i
didn't catch what they said as they were
saying it then when they hang up the
live transcription disappears so my one
suggestion for google would be to let me
like have a saved copy of that live
transcription in case they just hang up
the battery life on the pixel 3 uh
pretty unremarkable very average
actually i'm averaging maybe four to
four and a half hours of screen on time
for my high brightness use for those
counting but your mileage may vary but
basically don't expect this to go like
all day and then some it's definitely a
one-day phone but again wireless
charging is welcome i'm doing it a lot
more now with my primary device now that
it supports it i've also had some
conversations with google about things
that i was complaining about before like
things that weren't optimized yet bugs
they've already promised that they're
going to fix my complaint in the last
video which was the fact that full
screen videos weren't centered on pixel
3 xl they're going to change that so
that's awesome shows they're listening
so while we're at it here's a couple
other things that aren't quite right so
instagram still needs to update their
stories uh yahoo fantasy app is still
cut off at the top and so is youtube
studio and i've also had this bug with
background apps that i can try to demo
so this bug i've had i don't know if
it'll do it now but we'll see i'll be in
a music app
playing music and a lot of times i'm
connected to bluetooth whatever it's
supposed to be playing in the background
then i'll open the camera app and i'll
just take one photo
and a lot of times that's enough to
close the music app in the background
and completely stop it from playing not
only like pausing music but closing it
and i have to reopen it and the track
starts over it's a weird it seems like a
memory thing i kind of wonder if this
would still happen with six or eight
gigs of ram maybe it wouldn't but uh
maybe it's just an easily fixable bug
all right i've made you wait long enough
let's get to the last big puzzle piece
of this phone
one of the big reasons you're all
probably here and one of the reasons
this phone has been so hyped among
content creators youtubers people like
that
it's this camera so google's stuck with
one camera on the back in a world where
we literally have multiple phones coming
out with three or four cameras on the
back
and google is super stubborn with one
but as they should because their
software and their image processing is
everything so i'll just say it straight
up pixel 3 takes the best photos of any
smartphone camera better than iphone 10s
better than red hydrogen better than any
samsung or any lg phone better than
pixel 2 but i don't want to just tell
you that it's good i want to tell you
why it's good pixel 3 photos have a plus
detail a plus dynamic range a plus
autofocus and now even better warmer i
think more accurate colors pixel 2
tended to be a little bit cool the
sensor is big enough that you can pretty
often create a real natural shallow
depth of field when you take a photo of
something close enough so you don't need
to use portrait mode very often but when
you do use portrait mode the edge
detection is getting better every year
and it's excellent at this point so the
typical photo from a pixel 3 camera has
a super strong dynamic range it's tack
sharp from corner to corner which is my
kind of camera my only complaint would
be sometimes the hdr can feel too
aggressive like you know that effect
when you have an overdone hdr which can
kind of look like a halo around the high
contrast areas that's hard to edit out
and so you got to retake the photo when
that happens but other than that there's
not a lot to dislike about pixel 3's
camera it has me confident as i'm taking
photos that they're going to be good no
matter what uh and none of that like ai
tweaking the colors after you take the
photo stuff no over processing it's just
a good camera and on top of all that
there are some other smart features that
they've added this year so motion
autofocus is particularly good you tap
something on the screen and it locks
focus basically on that object and
tracks it around the frame
not only does it work well but it's like
an added confidence booster that what
you're going to take a photo of will
stay in focus super resume which i was
pretty hyped for
didn't turn out that drastic i don't
actually use digital zoom that much but
i found that when i do go past about 5x
things start to get kind of water colory
like a like a watercolor painting i'm
not sure if super resume is actually
preserving any extra detail here in fact
side by side with the iphone 10s at full
zoom it looks like the iphone preserves
more detail which i guess you'd expect
when it has a telephoto lens so yeah
it's a cool concept in theory but i
think it still needs some work to
actually catch up to optical zoom it
might be a while but i will say from
like 1x to 3x zoom pixel pretty much
always looks great and then of course
for selfie takers pixel 3 has absolutely
the best selfie camera i have ever seen
selfie portrait mode is really good and
of course having a second even wider
angle camera is gonna let you get more
in the shot whether it's more people or
more background or whatever you're into
but just generally not a whole lot of
beauty mode it's tack sharp what you see
is what you get and then in the video
front it's still a mixed bag i still say
iphone is the best video camera in any
smartphone as long as pixel 3 doesn't
have 4k 60 uh and it still has slightly
more washed out colors and a somewhat
inconsistent exposure but it's still
pretty good stabilization is absolutely
impeccable this is actually a handheld
shot but it looks like it's on a tripod
which is ridiculous but the microphone
is still not that great so if you were
thinking about vlogging with this
smartphone you this probably isn't the
one overall though as a single camera
system pixel 3 is really impressive it's
just a master class in computational
photography and just how much software
really matters in 2018 so basically i
want to give a shout out to the verge's
review title which i actually think
pretty much nailed it best it paints the
picture that i agree with which is
the best camera in a smartphone
gets a better phone
the best camera gets a better phone if
you scroll down to the comment section
right now i pretty much guarantee the
first three comments all have the word
notch in them pretty much guarantee it
go ahead scroll down see for yourself
it's like a catch 22. if all we do is
talk about this notch every time the
phone comes up then we kind of have to
ignore how good the rest of the phone is
but if we don't talk about the notch
then they might get the idea that we
like the notch or that we're into it
which we're not so how good this phone
is will be overshadowed by how bad this
notch is that's the way it's going to be
and that's everyone's fault that's our
fault that's google's fault for making
it this way that's reviewer's fault
that's commenter's faults it's
everyone's fault i don't think google
cares if this phone sells much i think
what they do care about is flexing what
they're good at which at this point is
software
machine learning and ai
and if you can see that and appreciate
it then you'll like this phone you
should get this phone for the camera
and or the software they're both best in
class and beyond that there isn't any
really huge reason to get this phone but
it's true the best camera just got a
better phone and i'm really happy about
that so i'll be carrying this phone for
that reason for now
anyway that's the review until the next
one thanks for watching
catch you later peace